e aí galera beleza também pelo caso o
hara tenho 26 4 27 anos é também
conhecido aqui pelos corredores como o
show do jacareí tom e o papo de hoje com
vocês sobre profissão e o título caso da
praça palestra é desconstruir o meu
diploma me deu o maior tesão do mundo
muita calma mas mas eu não vou bater na
grade da faculdade mas tem a ver com um
caminho que eu seguir e que talvez essa
conversa ajude
alguns de vocês ou alguma situação que
vocês vão passar agora ou daqui pra
frente
muita calma e mel vai dar tudo certo por
me considerar a contemporânea você me
formei aqui em 2014 então vai não sou
tão velho assim eu acho que nós vivemos
coisas parecidas os trabalhos da
faculdade
afinal saudades festas tv jardim apa
entidades da tv jogos joguei vôlei foi
acordado mais as coisas que nós adoramos
bastante e todas as atividades na
verdade elas me ajudaram a construir
quem eu sou hoje é claro mas esses
quatro anos na faculdade eu construí
pensando no que eu tinha como sonho na
época e o meu maior sonho era me tornar
um redator publicitário
eu tinha vontade de ser um redator
grande trabalhar em uma agência grande
me inscrevi em prêmio ganhar prêmio eu
estava no meu sexto semestre é
preparando portfólio tudo mais
eu consegui entrar na agência que eu
mais queria um dia uma pessoa que
trabalhava nessa gente haverá uma
palestra é e aí eu fiquei encantado fui
atrás conseguiu um estágio na agência
comecei a crescer nessa agência foi
promovido pelo relator júnior
depois foi promovido para redator pleno
e aí comecei a ganhar prêmio eu falei
que esse cara transfor não tinha
informado ainda e trabalhe alcançar meu
sonho está tudo voando
literalmente eu acordei eu estava com
bode
ele estava com um body absurdo de pra
agência um lugar que todos os dias eu
tinha o tesão maravilhoso e fala cara é
isso que quero fazer parte da minha vida
mas eu não tava mais eu ia falar de saco
cheio
a propaganda em seu jeito que eu estava
escrevendo que está trabalhando para o
de fazer completamente sentido pra mim
eu me sentia fora de de uma realidade de
que se inscrevendo mentira assim sabe
não me completava o sonho acabou
e aí que você faz quando tudo o que você
acredita quando tudo que você mais
queria quando o que fazia sentido para
você para desistir para de fazer sentido
o seu sonho para de this is it para você
sobre isso eu quero falar com vocês
quando a gente está ali naquele trabalho
e de repente se fala cara do mal e pede
tomar usam assim o que a gente faz
quando você não sabe mais pra onde ir
não nós não vamos continuar a nadar há
ainda porque antes de nadar eu descobri
que é muito importante você se conhecer
pergunta quem já fez terapia é muito bom
mas porque terapia é bom
terapia é bom porque terapia é a gente
olhar pra dentro
mas a gente se conhecer e se conhecendo
a gente começa a perceber coisas que a
gente gosta a gente começa a entender as
decisões melhores pra gente se
conhecendo
a gente sabe que a gente gosta e
descobrir a gente gosta tem mais chance
da gente perceber que uma coisa tem a
ver comigo outra coisa não tem a gente
começa a perceber no que a gente é bom
em fazer o que pode me dar prazer e
perceba
esse é um tipo de coisa que as pessoas
não podem impor em você só você tem essa
resposta que você gosta de falar que
você gosta de salsicha você não basta só
sei que não vai ser disse se você vai
comer
o importante é você olhar pra dentro
pegar essas pessoas que estão falando
que você deveria fazer isso e aquilo
esquecer um pouquinho porque elas podem
querer seu bem mas só você dentro de
você sabe o que faz sentido para a sua
vida
e pra isso você precisa se conhecer e se
conhecendo
você pode tomar essa decisão e descobri
isso que vai despertar de novo esse
tesão no que você vai fazer parte da sua
vida beleza então descobriu gosto ou
teve uma idéia de uma estudada pensei um
pouquinho eu acho que o que eu tenho
aptidão a fazer mais ou menos isso aqui
que eu faço agora pra que lado eu começo
a andar acima pega essa coisa que você
gostou e mira lá no alto
bom eu gosto de chamar que coloca o
norte na sua carreira que esse norte é o
ponto mais alto é o ápice da satisfação
profissional que você vai ter nesse
negócio
eu vou contar um pouquinho agora da
minha trajetória é pra tentar
materializar um pouco mais pra vocês e
da atenção que depois eu vou quebrar
essa historinha em alguns pedacinhos
depois do cansado da vida da agência
procurei mil coisas é do que eu poderia
fazer eu conversando com a minha chefe
na época a agência fernanda romano ela
falou cara talvez tenha uma oportunidade
aqui um amigo meu que está montando uma
equipe nova e tem a ver com você então
fui eu tomo equipe de conteúdo na espn
fui participar uma equipe de produção de
conteúdo no que eu pisei lá dentro e
comecei a respirar o ar do jornalismo
esportivo minha vida completamente mudou
aquilo começou a fazer muito sentido
para mim eu comecei a voltar a ter tesão
em trabalhar a ficar feliz e descobrir
novas possibilidades
eu comecei a mergulhar naquele falei
cara tudo que eu aprendia na minha vida
inteira eu posso usar de outras formas
aqui e foi isso eu comecei a fazer e
começou a descobrir e comecei atrás e
meio que me enfiar assim o espaço que eu
tinha para poder crescer lá dentro
e aí eu parei e pensei finalmente acho
que eu descobri meu novo norte
acho que eu posso traçar um objetivo
maior assim do que eu posso fazer parte
da minha vida
e aí eu decidi que a partir dali eu ia
me tornar um apresentador completa
o norte é que eu quero ser um
comunicador capaz de falar sobre
qualquer coisa eu posso fazer um
programa de culinária eu posso fazer um
programa de música possa mediar o debate
e para apresentar um programa de
esportes que foi como eu comecei fazendo
não perceba é o norte é ousado porque
não sou nada disso ainda não tenho a
pretensão de pretensioso o suficiente
ainda para achar capazes de fazer isso
mas a minha vontade é essa que um dia eu
cheguei lá eo norte é usado justamente
porque você marca e lá em cima e aos
poucos você vai caminhando em direção a
ele você vai sentindo chegando mais
perto de seu sonho
você vai traçando o seu caminho ele pode
dar voltas mas você sabe que no final
das contas o que é onde você quer chegar
a esse ponto mais alto agora resumindo a
minha história eu cansei de uma coisa
que eu aparentemente gostava muito
alguém me oferecer uma oportunidade eu
experimentei essa oportunidade e eu
posso dizer até que antes disso eu
experimentei uma coisa que teoricamente
gostava descobri que não e depois eu
entrei no universo e esse universo me
deu um montão de novas idéias
vamos passo a passo eu experimentei para
experimentar e aí você pode até falar
todo mundo aqui trabalhou ou um dia vai
trabalhar num lugar que odeia quem não
gosta que sabe que não faz sentido e
muita gente muitas vezes a gente até
pensa que não vale a pena e no lugar que
você já sabe que você acha que não gosta
por que você acha que não faz sentido
mas comigo
só tem um jeito de você realmente
descobrir que você não gosta de alguma
coisa é experimentando experimentar
descobrir que não gosta também é andar
pra frente
no mínimo você tira isso da sua frente
beleza eu não gostava disso mesmo tá
garantida mas pode ter certeza que nesse
meio do caminho alguma coisa você vai
aprender alguma pessoa você vai conhecer
que vai te falar uma coisa que vai
levantar uma luz a cabeça então como
diria um professor aqui o spm todo o
conhecimento é relevante
então por mais que você só tinha da
frente sem jogo
eu cansei e larguei gente
larry co tem que deixar rolar o negócio
porque mais por mais que você tenha
encontrado um lugar se você acha
perfeito como foi o meu caso na espn e
espn e na espn
eu aprendi que chegou uma hora que bateu
um teto e eu não tava mais aprendendo
mais ali dentro eu estava distante do
meu sonho
outro começando a ficar estagnado num
ponto então eu resolvi largar o quanto
aquele lugar tem para te ensinar também
tem que ser uma medida de análise sua
para você conseguir continuar andando
para frente e se descobrir saber a hora
de sair de largar é tão importante ou
mais importante quanto você encontrar
uma coisa que faz sentido para você
isso é muito importante alguém me
ofereceu uma oportunidade gente
quanto mais amigos você tiver na sua
vida quanto mais gente você trazer para
perto de seu sonho mais energia você vai
ter pra empurrar esse sonho pra frente
quanto mais gente você conhece quanto
mais contato você faz mais oportunidades
vão aparecendo
você vai conhecer alguém que vai
conhecer outro alguém que vai conhecer
outro alguém que vai ter uma ideia que
vai fazer sentido com o que você gosta
que vai ter uma outra pessoa que vai
apresentar alguém que vai ajudar vou com
você no quarto e conseguiu fazer sua
carreira
ninguém faz nada sozinho
mesmo que se alguém te deu uma porrada
na cabeça e de ensinar uma coisa e vai
dizer que isso é uma coisa que pode ter
ajudado uma coreia unificada que
inventou a lâmpada
ele não ficou livre cosa laboratório lá
fazendo a lâmpada dele mas alguém de um
insight para ele alguém levou um
sanduíche para ele comer e as pessoas e
não pode tirar o mérito da ajuda né eu
acho que é muito legal a gente
reconhecer todo o universo de pessoas
que dão lhe que no seu post e fizeram
seu dia melhor também por que não
e por último eu entrei num novo universo
e teve novas idéias
essa parte até voltando aqui nesta
escola pra contar
eu fico até emocionado porque é muito
doido pensar que quatro anos atrás
recebeu de como depositário e em 2015
o universo novo e aí de repente uma ex
colega minha da faculdade me mandou um e
mail com um link de um processo seletivo
eu apliquei processo seletivo eu
descobri que ele tinha tudo a ver comigo
e no começo do ano agora eu fui cobrir
uma copa do mundo é muito surreal pensar
que eu ia nas aulas e renato mada e
ficava feliz e depende que o pai faz
sentido eu não sabia mas para onde a
minha vida a minha e de repente numa
velocidade monstruosa eu estava
trabalhando do maior canal do brasil um
dos maiores do mundo como repórter
eu durante muito tempo é meu time
considerado com esse título de
jornalista porque não têm essa formação
mas eu fui ganhando essa experiência e
ela passou a ser verdade pra mim eu
entro ao vivo nos lugares agora eu já
não me vejo mais apenas como um
publicitário que quer ser jornalista
eu me vejo como um cara que desconstruiu
tudo o que ele tinha e criou uma coisa
nova um jeito novo de falar desconstruir
o diploma realmente me deu uma artesã do
mundo e eu de novo não é simplesmente
você pegar o diploma e rasgar ou ter
novas idéias é pegar tudo isso que você
aprendeu pegar tudo isso que você tem
que criar uma coisa nova que faz sentido
para você e que vai dar prazer
por último eu queria deixar a única
mensagem que eu acho que é importante
disso tudo é pra vocês não terem medo
não tenham medo de arriscar
não tenham medo de descobrir novas
possibilidades não têm medo de descobrir
o que você gosta ou que você não gosta
o cara tem a ver com o seu futuro tem a
ver com o que você quer fazer e eu
também não quero que vocês fiquem
achando que eu estou falando uma grande
verdade aqui muito pelo contrário
mas eu tenho certeza que se cada um de
vocês olhar pra dentro
se descobrir um pouquinho e à risca e
não tem medo de errar não ter medo de
largar conhecer pessoas e trazer gente
para perto sempre vocês vão está tendo a
chance de ter esse prazer que eu tenho
que é todo dia acordar e me sentir
caminhando às vezes com passos mais
curtos e descompassos mais longos mas
sempre em direção ao meu sonho
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]